you
err our live webinars from Google cloud
we're hosting webinars every Tuesday and
we're really happy to have you here with
us
my name is Yuri Greenstein I'm a
customer engineer here at Google cloud
and I'm incredibly happy and excited to
have Carter Maslan the founder and CEO
of cameo with us today Carter thank you
so much for being here I'm happy to be
here
fantastic you can ask questions any time
on the platform will have Googlers on
standby to answer them we'll also be
doing a live Q&A later in the program so
first of all Carter again thank you for
being here and congratulations on your
best of CES award thank you just
extremely excited about that great so
today we'll be talking about how you
have built Cameo to provide machine
learning for video intelligence to your
customers so perhaps we just start by
you telling us the the problem you set
out to solve yeah so cameo is real-time
video search that works with any camera
stream and the big problem with video
today is that in recording hours and
hours of video there's only a certain
small fraction of it that's actually
warranting any attention from humans and
so getting machines to do that work for
you to highlight what's interesting is
the core of what cameo is about so that
real-time video search will
automatically identify the few two
minutes perhaps each out of etch every
day that is weren't in your attention
fantastic so why don't we have you show
us kind of exactly what this looks like
in practice that'd be good we'll jump to
a demo where I can just do a quick
search and I'll just start by looking at
a single camera like Liverpool which is
a public library in New York and the
first thing to notice is that there's no
dead airtime so then the first level of
machine learning is just highlighting
interesting events that warrant your
attention over a large period of time
but you can do quick searches like this
I can just say I'm looking for people in
red or blue on the sidewalk and now out
of a two or three week period I'm seeing
every time there was a person that was
either in red or blue
across the sidewalk including a quick
chart for the frequency you can just see
this is all the times that people in
blue all the times people in red or all
the time that there were people period
and that same thing applies you can
still play the video behind the event
but you can also do advanced searches
like if I only want to see when there
were bikes across all the cameras you
can just type in bikes and now this is
using CNN's to label the events for the
cases where there was a bike and like
like I said before you can play even
this person that's dedicated in
wintertime snow biking it'll it'll find
that you can also do a quick search for
something as advanced as snow plow so
I'll just do a quick search snow plow
for that same period and so this is just
a quick example all these demos are
things that you can open in your browser
and do yourself at cameo comm demo
there's a sequence of links that you can
open without any kind of auth and follow
along as we do demos throughout this
discussion fantastic thank you so that
looks really cool and really impressive
you're able to very quickly you'll find
interesting things in these videos and
the UI is really fast and it looks like
you've been part of all a lot of value
can you give us a sense of you know who
might actually use this yeah so anybody
that has cameras large corporate
campuses cities even homes are using it
but it's basically the the core value of
cameos that it can work with the video
streams from old camera systems existing
camera systems your existing DVR and VR
and make it into something that's smart
and searchable and browsable so that it
learns what you find interesting in each
individual camera stream fantastic all
right so let's go back to our content
and resume there and I think the next
thing our audience would very much like
to understand is you know some of the
decisions that went into building cameo
and first you know why did you choose to
build it on
cheapy well we our founders came from
google so we were familiar with that at
the beginning but the core reason that
we chose GCP was the dynamic scalability
and quick deployment time so we deploy
several times a day and as a start-up
your core advantage is just listening to
what customers want and delivering it
quickly and to be able to hit the deploy
button you know several times a day
without the hassles of any kind of
hardware issues or maintenance issues
that was a big one but then the core of
the problem is just matched to the
dynamic scaling so this chart I don't
know if you can present this chart of a
real life deployment with 62 cameras
that shows the number of events over the
time and of time of day and you can see
that it's very spiky it's you know five
times the traffic during a daytime
shopping mall versus the nighttime and
when you have that kind of a problem
where you're saying well tell me what's
interesting out of hours of video with
this kind of spiky activity level having
the dynamic provisioning automatically
scale your compute resources to match
what you're analyzing is a key strength
so rather than having to deal with
on-site on-premise hardware that has to
be provisioned at peak capacity you can
instead provision at a much lower
dynamic rate that's much more
cost-efficient and much more bandwidth
efficient mm-hm
yeah I think you make it really
important point here is that it would be
really difficult to achieve optimization
using any kind of a traditional
on-premise infrastructure with a
workload and a demand that looks like
this I mean this is incredibly spiky
right like you said I think you're your
delta between your baseline here and
your peak is it looks to be at least 5x
if not more right I mean you have some
cameras that might be like a mechanical
room or a server room where credit card
data is processed where there's very low
activity and then you've got others that
are like the main entrance for a
shopping mall you know and so it's not
just hour of day but it's by kind of the
venue of the camera and so making that
cost efficient is the core focus is you
know how do you take
the mass of millions of existing cameras
and connect them to state-of-the-art
machine learning at a price point that
makes sense for people on a business
perspective yeah absolutely makes a lot
of sense all right so this looks really
interesting let's move on to kind of how
this actually works so it looks like
there's really four major components to
Cameo right there's the customers
on-premise infrastructure which is what
they need to collect the video and send
it to the cloud for processing there's
all the stuff that happens in the cloud
there's the user experience which is
delivered via web and native mobile apps
and then there are the hook as well
which we'll cover that later on so let's
first start by talking about what does
the customer of yours need to really do
this let's start with the cameras I
think you said this already that they
can use their existing cameras as well
as new ones but are these
special-purpose cameras or can they just
be any camera they can literally be any
camera that the nice thing is that Cameo
analyzes the h.264 video stream itself
that comes from the camera directly or
from a network video recorder like a DVR
or a video management system of EMS and
so no matter where it comes from your
existing cameras even analog cameras
that are connected through one of those
NVRs can be accessed via Cameo so in
terms of a customer's deployment they
can light up their existing cameras in
less than 10 minutes because as long as
the cameras are on a network that's all
that's needed fantastic
so then the second part of their
on-premise infrastructure would be the
network video recorder or video
management systems so one you know is
that a required component and and two
how does that system really play into
this so so the network video recorder or
VMs is usually used to provide the
complete archive of HD video on-site on
premise so you can either use that or go
direct to the cloud you can choose so it
becomes it becomes mainly an issue of
like what's your uplink bandwidth what
are your archive and retention
requirements and things but you're free
to serve the video streams from the NVR
or from the camera it doesn't matter
which
very cool and then the third part of
their on-premise deployment is this
thing that's just called box that sounds
awfully mysterious can you tell us a bit
about what the box is yes the box is a
video gateway it's basically a device
that analyzes the video streams on the
local network so you get a huge
bandwidth efficiency gain because the
all of the analysis and metadata that's
observed about each 12 second video
event is analyzed locally by the box and
the box is in this kind of chatty
conversation with the cloud saying hey
do you find this interesting you know
based on what you've seen the user do do
you think the user wants this and all of
those decisions in that chatty
conversation are determining what
happens subsequently in analyzing the
video and that's where the big cost
efficiencies come from because you know
you saw the spikes and if if a camera's
even with high activity if only a
fraction of it is interesting like when
when a person approaches the server room
that houses your credit card data that's
when you want HD recording with full
analysis and integration with their
Security Operations Center and things so
all of those kinds of decisions are made
locally by the machine learning that's
running on box and and and we'll talk
about later what machine learning unbox
does but the second thing that box does
is gives you security so you remember
the mirai virus I do yes so that was a
massive attack that was using people's
cameras and DVRs the vulnerability in
them because the traditional deployment
model for cameras on corporate campuses
and things for when you need remote
viewing was that forward inbound ports
and since box is only over ssl port 443
you can completely close your local
network to inbound network requests you
know so in addition to its efficiency
function there's also a really good
security function because you can now
close all inbound ports on your local
networks to avoid a repeat of the mirai
virus fantastic all right so we've got
our cameras they're capturing all this
video we have there our NV our VMs
that's archiving all the HD video and we
have the box that's basically kind of it
choosing which bids to actually send
from the cloud for processing so which
takes us to the part that I think most
folks on line are here to actually see
which is yeah what are you doing in the
cloud yeah so let's move into that let's
kind of cover three major paths that I
think are gonna be interesting to to our
audience first is kind of what you're
doing with the video when it arrives the
second one will be kind of how you're
delivering that user experience right
you showed us the UI it's incredibly
fast it's really responsive and its
operating young obviously what a fairly
complex data says so I'd love to hear
about how you're really making that as
performant as it is and then the thirdly
we'll talk about how you're taking both
the videos are data as well as the user
interaction data and combining them to
power your ml that's sound good that
sounds good all right so let's talk
about the video first you've got your
cameras you got your box box sends video
to the cloud what happens then so as I
mentioned there's a front end that's
basically in the chatty conversation
with the box and so we use App Engine
standard as that front end for the
dynamic scaling and responsiveness to
both api's queries and end-user search
api queries and so that is the initial
entry point is the google front end
that's talking to an app engine standard
set of instances and then those
decisions made at the beginning based on
the trained models to that point
determine all the subsequent workflow
that you see on the right side of this
chart so what level of analysis should
get should be applied to this where
should the storage go so if you if you
want to just have a response that says
hey for this video send it to Nearline
storage because it's unlikely to be
reviewed so for cost efficiency just let
me give you a sign GCS RL and just send
it straight to GCS vs. this is an
important event so let's call the hooks
that are things like google vision API
or other specialized classifiers because
this is particularly important all of
that workflow is determined after it
goes through the front end with these
dynamically provisioned App Engine
standard instances it makes a lot of
sense that you're using App Engine
standard because of the
come the big spike eNOS that you have in
your traffic right that's okay the sort
of a textbook used for use keys for App
Engine right when you have sort of very
unpredictable workloads very spiky
workloads App Engine can scale as high
as it needs to it can scale down as low
as it needs to all the way to zero
although obviously with camera sources
you probably never
you're quite at zero but it certainly
makes a lot of sense that you're using
App Engine that way yeah I mean for the
people that are opening the demo page
cameo comm slash demo your queries are
spinning up instances in response to
your individual queries because there's
a mismatch out of the workload for
recording and analyzing video versus
querying video because you do much less
querying so there's also the dynamic
provisioning based on you guys going to
the website right now and doing your own
searches those are spinning up instances
to make sure you get good you know good
response times fantastic all right so
that kind of helps us to understand what
you're doing with the video as it comes
to the platform now let's talk about all
those users out there that are again
going to cameo comm slash demo and
actually trying to stop for themselves
how are you were delivering that that
experience so there's a front-end query
parser that kind of determines based on
what's observed in your camera feeds
what you're asking for so when you do a
search like you know Toyota Prius
yesterday 1:00 p.m. its parsing that and
knows that Toyota Prius is a make and
model of a car that you're looking for
in your feed so the first step is just
understanding your query and that
language has some natural language
processing of the query itself so you
can say you know one day ago at noon and
also terms and labels that are
applicable to your cameras and that's
all served from datastore so a datastore
is indexed based on both the time the
camera source the user all that stuff to
make it fast and searchable and the
video itself is served from Google Cloud
storage and in the process of taking in
video there's a whole bunch of workflows
that are triggered from both cloud
dataflow and just task queues and
pub/sub that are triggered based on the
content of the video um so that's
actually I think an interesting point
can you tell us a little bit about kind
of how you're using App Engine task
queues and data flow and kind of what
are the two things that you're achieving
with those I guess on the task queue
front the big value that we actually
didn't anticipate when we first started
using task queues was just how resilient
it is and we learned some in terms of
like if you have a temporary memcache
failure or temporary datastore failure
there's seamless to the users there's no
impact because it gets retried and it's
a really nice mechanism to have
communication among modules and versions
of your app so in our case our
application is split with a lot in
Python and a lot of the front-end in
Java we have modules that have different
kinds of workloads
and task queues are easy way to
coordinate functions among them reliably
without kind of any risk of loss of data
or loss of the request the same thing
with pub/sub we use pub/sub for simple
things like if a if a batch operation is
completed somebody might have created a
time lapse let's say so they may have
said give me a time lapse of my camera
from 8 a.m. Monday to 5 p.m. Friday on a
construction site when that's completed
we'll use pub/sub just to notify people
of the completion including our internal
processes that'll do the billing and
stuff so it's just been a really good
flexible mechanism to coordinate
communication across all the different
modules and application versions so
you're using task queues to kind of do
some of that orchestration between
modules you're using pub/sub to do some
of that communication and things like
notifications or pops up what's what's
the role of dataflow in this
architecture
we're mainly using the mappers for
dataflow not so much the reducing but we
do do periodic summaries of counters
because Cameo is all based on a usage
based billing so dataflow helps us go
over massive amounts of events I mean
each each camera each each day there's
millions of events to be summarized on
how many megabytes have been uploaded
how many important events how many
unimportant events all of those things
are done via data flow including the
triggers to manage billing cycles and
things that are driven off of those
counters fantastic alright so now we've
covered kind of what you're doing with
the video as it comes in from the camera
through the box and there's ingested
we've covered what kind of what you're
doing to provide that user experience in
the UI
tell me how you combining those two data
sources to actually do machine learning
in the platform yeah that's the key
thing is that the neural nets that are
being trained are on a camera specific
basis so so on the on the box itself
there's something that we call
internally adaptive motion filtering
which is a set of neural nets that are
all concurrently competing to be right
about what's interesting for that
particular camera and you know the the
tricky thing in cameras is that it's not
just about eliminating spurious pixel
motion because there are a lot of times
where a scene has something that is a
real object moving but it's just not
interesting like you could have in the
front of a commercial building entrance
a tree that has just a blowing branch
that is just swaying periodically it is
a real object moving but it's not
interesting and so the box itself has
neural nets that are learning that that
swaying branch is not interesting but
then the feedback loops that the that
come from you using the product so when
you play an event or you share an event
or you save an event or you give it an
explicit thumbs-up or thumbs-down kind
of like your rating songs those all are
now collected training feedback for your
individual camera so even though there's
no visibility into what your camera is
actually observing it's still can train
itself based on the way that you use the
product and so those those things
surface and the clean summary of your
video and kind of the precision of the
search results but also in some
efficiency things so I was going to show
one example of that efficiency part of
the machine learning yeah let's do that
so we'll do one more
this is a demo that we call the matrix
demo and part of the machine learning is
identifying what is interesting versus
not interesting and in this case there's
a lot of passing street traffic that'll
be in low res fast time-lapse and then
when the person that's approaching the
sidewalk which is the nighttime library
that you want to actually observe it'll
slow down into full HD recording so this
is why we call it the matrix effect
because you'll see the passing street
traffic as low res fast time-lapse and
then it slows down to HD right as the
person comes into view so we love that
as an example of machine learning that
is smart enough to differentiate between
passing street traffic and the people
that you're actually trying to protect
at night at the library yeah and that's
actually really amazing not only does it
know that hey something is happening
that's different than what was happening
before it's something that might be
interesting I now need to provide
additional context around that and like
you said right give you that kind of
full frame high definition feed now so
someone who is kind of looking at this
video after the fact can actually you
know make decisions around what did they
see is it something that they need to
take out yeah and and just from an
economics perspective you're saving both
bandwidth and storage and processing
costs by kind of this was when we first
started talking we were talking about
the power efficiency you know of having
machine learning make decisions on what
compute resources are applied to any
particular video event yeah and it's not
dissimilar from some of the things that
I've read on the machine learning that
did a better job managing power in
Google Data Centers than humans and so
it's similar for your video feeds where
we're actually having the machines help
you save bandwidth and compute costs by
knowing what warrants the extra work yep
fantastic all right so now that we've
seen a demo let's get back to our
content here and the next question I
have is now there's we sort of
understand kind of what you're doing
with the data in GCP and we understand
some of the use cases that are sort of
their quote unquote
out of the box although
not the cameo box I imagine you have
lots of customers that come to you and
ask you to do things that the platform
has not been built to do how do you
support kind of new use cases new
classifiers and new requirements that
was one of the key design criteria for
Cameo is that we wanted it to be a video
processing pipeline that's open on both
ends so not only is it open to all
cameras but it's open to all machine
learning classifiers and third party
hooks so hooks are the way that Cameo
has an expensive pipeline and it's been
used for things as funny as like we had
no classifier for fish faces and there
was a cattle competition to classify
yellowfin tuna versus bluefin tuna
versus marlin and sharks and it's as
simple as defining a hook in the Cameo
pipeline where you can say you know when
the fish door opens or when there's a
human on deck I want you to run
additional classifiers that are smart
enough to differentiate between types of
fish and that's not an expertise we have
but in the old adage there's more smart
people outside of your company than in
your company that's the reason that we
have hooks is that now all that grunge
work of getting you know millions of
cameras connected and being able to be
processed there are now accessible to
third parties that may specialize in
face recognition whether they're fishing
faces or other or you know access
control systems that want to be
integrated all of this is an extensible
thing so you just register hook and do
the additional analysis that you'd like
to do fantastic so hooks are a great way
for folks to take advantage of the
pipeline that you've built to do like
you said classification that is in there
out of the box yeah I mean in this
example this was not even additional
classification if you look at this
command
it's basically I'll just do a quick walk
through you're saying when there's a
match on this query so it's much like if
you've used Google Alerts
search alerts absolutely it's the same
thing in Cameo when you pin a query that
now becomes an alert that's the same
thing that drives the API for hooks you
basically say whenever there's people 2
a.m. to 5 a.m. on the
rooftop this is an example of a query do
this which in this case was a request to
have a callback or all that would just
schedule a guard on premise guard tour
so now instead of just having your
on-site security staff roam you're
getting targeted alerts based on query
matches so this curl command it's a
single simple command that just says
when that query match happens call me
back giving me the payload of which
camera source observed it what the
earliest and latest time was and what we
labeled it with and now that can drive
your scheduling system for a guard tour
it can drive your notification systems
it can do anything so this is the
flexibility and extending via hooks
fantastic so it looks a great way to
kind of get additional information they
may not be they're out of the box you
know how would you go about
understanding like when things are
happening so in your example right I
know that I saw people in the rooftop
kind of between the specific hours but
what if I want to know exactly when
someone opened that hatch for example
and it started crying yeah how do I go
about doing that so there's a maybe we
could look at annotations quickly this
is an example where part of the pipeline
enables you to correlate any label to a
timestamp and that means that any device
whether it's a door sensor or an access
control badge in can now be a source of
annotating a video feed so if you want
to say
let me show me every time that the fish
door was opened it's simple to see that
in video because this one command just
says put these labels badge one two
three unlocked as a door unlock event
now whenever you search for show me the
times that this door was unlocked you'll
see the video that matches those events
that come from those sensors so it's not
just about the video content but it's
also third-party devices and sensors
that can be integrated into that video
content fantastic so now we've covered
kind of hooks and annotations which are
which ways by which other people can
again take advantage of the platform in
the pipeline you've built thank you so
much for that before we get into the Q&A
I wanted to ask you one last question
you know kind of as you've built out
your infrastructure and your platform on
GCP you know there any lesson is that
you've learned that you think our
audience would benefit from yeah I mean
I think if I were to summarize kind of
some of the top lessons from the past
years of working with GCP one of the
first ones is in terms of your data if
you're using data store make sure you
think in terms of key value buckets
because if you come from a relational
background you may be tempted to just
take your relational thinking into
datastore and if you want to avoid
problems with eventual consistency and
indexing update times and things like
that
think of your data as atomic key value
buckets rather than as rows in a
relational table that's that's probably
one yeah that's - in terms of
performance we found that almost always
when you profile your application for
performance our PCs remote procedure
calls are the culprits so think about
how you do things in parallel so if
you're if you have like a list of events
that you're going to display on the
screen like you're seeing with our
search results do a batch get you know
so that you've got a list of 60 keys
that you're fetching in one RPC that can
all be in parallel rather than doing
that sequentially so that's another
lesson I'm trying to think of other
highlights that we've learned but those
are two starting though those are very
good and not on that second point I'll
make a bit of a product pitch which is
folks if you're interested in
understanding the performance of the our
pcs in your application take a look at
the trace functionality within
stackdriver it can really expose those
slow running our pcs until you know
exactly where some of the latency in
your application calls may be well
awesome thank you so much I think now we
will take a quick break please stay
tuned for the live QE Q&A and we will be
back in less than one minute
you
welcome back let's go through some of
the questions that you have for us our
first question is how does cameo charge
if customers given how much heavy
processing you're doing
that's a great question we had one point
it started with like a fixed monthly
price and we realized quickly that the
workloads vary so much by what the
camera is observing so you could have a
really inexpensive camera and a quiet
server room with credit card processing
data and a really busy camera observing
a parking garage and so we have
usage-based pricing so you can pay on a
per gigabyte basis and that enables you
to tune the machine-learning we also
wanted to have that incentive where as
it gets smarter your prices go down
and so basically Cameo has custom plans
that our partners offer that are all
tuned to your specific video processing
needs including duration of storage do
you need 90 days storage a year storage
what kinds of advanced analytics do you
want do you want car classification or
just OCR text recognition you know what
amount of events do you want processed
every day all of these things are
variables that go into the pricing of a
plan so that you get the lowest process
possible price for your workload great
so it sounds like kind of the the two
real metrics are gonna be how much video
you're processing and then the second
part is kind of how complex the
processing is yep okay great all right
so next question is if I see something
interesting happening in the feed how do
I go about sharing the video to the
world and is this kind of the same as
traditional video sharing or you know
are you doing something different yeah
it's different in the sense that our
share via links we call them query links
when you share a link it's like sharing
a constrained view onto a feed that you
can revoke at any time so for everybody
that's used Google Docs sharing you have
an option where you can either add
somebody as a permanent collaborator or
you can just send a link and so we have
that same model you can either send a
link with so that when you're doing
these
demos on the cameo comm demo page that's
an example of query links because they
give you the right to access the content
just by having the token that is in that
query but if you have somebody that is
part of your security operations staff
for example they may be a permanent
guest on the account much like a
collaborator on a document but the
difference in cameos case is that the
the sharing can be constrained to
specific segments so it's like if you
could share a Google Doc but only one
paragraph of the document and I'll give
an example of that if I could do a demo
from a city camera here let me just this
is an example of a city camera that is
the last demo link on the demo page and
this is only 9:45 to 10 10 a.m. on the
last Friday and so the interesting thing
is if I try to scroll earlier it stops
at 9:45 even though there's a lot of
other video so this is the example of
sharing a paragraph within a doc but the
interesting thing is I can still search
within that query link that's shared
with me so if I want to do this search
I'll just say what I was really looking
for is a white Toyota now let me just
see if there was there was no white
Toyota at that point so let me just
certainly do a I'll just do look for a
white car and now I'm subsetting my
search to just be the events that had a
white a white car in them and so you can
do the same thing with a constrained
period of time where I can say I was
just looking for 9:50 a.m. to 950 2:00
a.m. on Friday and now because that is
within the constraints of the 9:45 210
sharing I can still do this so if you
take a scenario like the Boston Marathon
bombing where they had a thousand people
review video for three days to find the
suspects this kind of crowd-sourced
review gives you a secure way to share a
very limited
portion of your video stream but enables
people to do search refinements and
additional queries within the
constraints of what you shared and you
can add you cannot share by link but you
can also add people to the links of it
they still have to authenticate China
there's a that's the other level of
sharing is even when you share via link
you can still additionally require that
somebody be authenticated yeah so it
sounds like you have some very powerful
sharing capabilities both in allowing
other folks to view and collaborate in
the streams but also control kind of
what they can actually see to control
their access to perhaps specific slices
of time yeah or zones like you so you
could say if they can only see people
that are coming out of an elevator you
could have a zone elevator share only
that zone and then they can't see what's
happening over in another office room it
would only be the events that are
intersecting with the elevator yeah
fantastic I think that also answers our
next question about granularity of
access I think you've done a great job
of covering that sorry final question is
actually around the box believe it or
not so you know you're using your
gateway on-site to do pre processing and
then sending into the cloud how many
kind of parallel streams can can this
Gateway actually manage or maybe maybe a
broader question is how do you go by
deploying a system by which there are
you know many many many cameras so the
simple answer is I could just give you
the rough metrics it's because it's
dependent on the streams that are being
monitored so if you have 4k streams at
30 frames per second versus 720p streams
at 20 frames per second that's a big
difference sure but the the general
point is that it scales based on the
number of streams and the
characteristics of the stream so to give
an example just if you had just have
three HD 1080p streams at 30 frames per
second you can use a tiny little box
that will handle those three and then if
you go to six you can just linearly
stack more boxes okay but you can also
run box as a virtual machine on any set
of servers so if you have a hundred and
twenty cameras on campus you can run
that on a
single-server if it's beefy enough
understand so we have tools that
estimate you you enter in the
characteristics of your stream like I
have 1080p streams at 30 frames per
second at this four megabit encoding
rate and then it spits out your
recommended number of boxes based on the
number of CPUs and number of memory and
stuff so I hate to say it depends but it
really does depend we're trying to make
it simple by using a spreadsheet that is
on our site that will give you an answer
to this question is a help article on
how do i scale to the number of streams
that I'm monitoring fantastic all right
that's all the questions we had Carter
thank you so much for being here really
appreciated folks on on the stream thank
you so much for tuning in we sincerely
hope you have found this useful and
informative I think was a great way to
kind of showcase some of the really cool
capabilities of GCP things like auto
scaling and the ability to kind of
ingest these massive amounts of data and
do some machine learning processing on
them before we sign off I want to let
you know that if you've enjoyed this
format you should tune in to a more
formal sorry a less formal session that
we run once or twice a week it's called
the GCP online Meetup you can find us on
meetup.com or subscribe to us on youtube
at youtube.com slash GCP live we'll be
signing off but please stay tuned for
the next session called accelerating
your google cloud migration which should
be coming to you live from the Google
New York office shortly thank you and
have a great day
you